my whole life literally and uh coming
into this you know I didn't know we were
two weeks shy there's other people
already here establishing themselves but
although you feel like You Came in Like
The Underdogs some people haven't made
it as far as you
thank you very much I appreciate that
all right yeah so did you have fun when
you were with Nivea and stuff no
everything was great she's amazing
videos absolutely gorgeous but I am a
blue collar guy I never in my life would
imagine that would cross paths with
Evelyn and but here I am and who doesn't
love something that's beautiful
beyond curious
you're beyond curious yes about you okay
yeah you are stunning I can't even it's
I want to like fit your slipping yeah I
don't know I'm just saying you know what
we we think you're amazing it's still
not over you know what's gonna happen
you don't you're really sure I just want
you to enjoy yourself don't overthink
that's like the biggest thing in my life
in general it's not you know think less
dude
I want to talk to you about something
I'm the one who has or feels like I have
some sort of connection with you right
but it's like I keep calling you mystery
man it's like mixing of say for instance
every time like we'll do like the
get-togethers you'll be just and then
all of a sudden you're not and you're
like President that's what I I love that
right but yesterday I'm big on body
language and you was just like this the
whole time it just wasn't like it would
have been real different like if I put
something like real quick
you know what I'm saying I was like damn
I want to say something you
you can't yeah
Rayshawn he's just a hot ass mess man
I'm I'm focused yeah
he's drinking everything that he said
was just too much a little bit closer no
that's fine okay good you know
all right so it seems like we're abiding
yo you know we have like a sexual
chemistry so it's like the sexual
chemistry is a two-way street yes it is
okay
the truth comes out when people are
drinking you see a whole other side of
that person let's go get another drink
because I think you need one oh there's
a cucumber you know he just does too
much but it revealed a lot to me so is
this a problem
you are close I mean I'm not that's my
place
this is close
friend yeah come over here yeah yeah
just come over here
you know what I mean I got your back and
that's not cool in like one second it's
gonna be like to the point of no return
yeah disrespectful and it's like I'm
with you we're right here step across
that line